ferguson's is a downtown destination for
life is beautiful this weekend and
jillian takes us inside the flower
crowns cocktails and disco themed bar
take a look
yes well i have my flower crown ready
and we are back out here at ferguson's
we are calling it the downtown
destination for life is beautiful i am
joined by connie again and we started
our shopping we did our shopping bag we
had a lot of fun we picked out a few
items but you guys have even more to
offer here at ferguson tell me a little
bit about what else is on the table here
yeah so this is a collection of pretty
much most of our shops that we have here
so to start we have hats from all of our
country and water bottles because
there's a refill station that's going to
be right in front of us oh that's great
we have some unicorn snot so if you want
to get all glitz that would be perfect
for life is beautiful and postcards you
can send to your friends or family
members
you can have it directly sent out from
haymaker
really really cool
yeah and i was asking you earlier tell
me about this this is so cool yeah so
myron hensel he is he has a space here
so he actually does photographs exactly
onto wet colloidal silver plate so it's
a one-time one-stop shop so that's only
one thing
yeah it's a souvenir you can take home
with you from life is beautiful exactly
it's a technique that's from the 1800s
that is incredible okay what else do we
have over here we have mike's recovery
so that's something you want to for your
life is beautiful recovery we all will
need it after a few days out there
exactly and then mike's recovery will
actually be in the vip bathrooms this
specific scent oh this is great all
right a lot going on here a lot to shop
for and we see this colorful confetti
sparkly disco balls are floating in
front of us where are we right now this
is so cool so this is our rooftop deck
so this is going to probably be your
prime view you can get there's a bar up
here you can get drinks and that's going
to be our stage where there's going to
be three different dj collectives
that will be playing throughout the
throughout each day
so that's going to be this is going to
be the prime set and sketch events is
the ones who did our decorations for us
well i need this in my house this is a
dream come true i'm having so much fun
and life is beautiful isn't complete
without fashion music and the cocktail
so you guys have a new bar here at the
bar right yes so that is definitely
going to be your space too where you can
get drinks we're going to have food
there um definitely also a good place
where you can cool off yes speaking of
cooling off you know a good iced
cocktail some ac and we forgot to talk
about my favorite thing so uh tell me a
little bit about this and we gotta have
a moment for the fans
there you go you can find this in sun
and pisces which is another space in our
gather house so that's one of the
essentials i think is you'll want when
it gets a little spicy out here well
this is incredible i'm just living my
best life and you guys all can too
during life is beautiful be sure to come
check out ferguson you guys are open 2
to 10 p.m right yes well thank you for
this i'm just going to be enjoying my
fan
over here ready for life is beautiful
i'll send it back to you cheers to life
is beautiful
she is in her element okay thank you
jillian hope you're